yeah
sometimes I feel my heart will overflow
[Music]
sing along with wino Lionel Richie's hit
song hello it's from his Grammy winning
album can't slow down it is one of four
Grammys Richie has won out of 32
nominations he also has an Oscar for the
song say you say me from the movie White
Nights
Richie's latest recognition is a Kennedy
Center Honor the ceremony aired last
night right here on CBS Alex Wagner
spoke with Ritchie at his home in
Beverly Hills to learn how a shy boy
from Alabama became an influential star
[Music]
you hear about these awards for your
entire lifetime
[Music]
and then finally happens
my love song it's almost disbelief
you know Lionel my brother no one
deserves this award more than you do
[Music]
it's one of those things will make you
walk in the backyard sit down quiet
Lindo
how did this happen it happened because
of a decade's worth of massive hits
especially
[Music]
salads we've been called the king of
love songs my question is are you a
romantic I'm a hopeless disgusting
romantic I can fall in love in 15
seconds on anything and everybody when I
walk onstage I meet the people I've
never met before they know me forever I
walk out onstage and they're my old
friends right away what's it like I'm
date for you it's one big night of ham
sandwich and I just call it one big
great karaoke night
[Music]
because the more I give them to do the
louder they get
[Music]
do you think when you're playing it you
don't see and you don't think when
you're right I'll go over
[Music]
next day
then third day
[Music]
I mean if I'm me and then
[Music]
same card it doesn't go anywhere courts
don't change it's the melody here on top
Richi found music growing up in Tuskegee
Alabama his grandmother a classical
pianist taught him how to play were you
formally trained in terms of writing
music sheet music no I was I was
terrible and my grandmother god bless
her tried her best to teach me how to
play she would show me how to play the
piece properly on the piano with the
hand movement and instead of watching
the music I would watch her hands she
would leave and say go rehearse and I'll
be back in a moment and I could play by
ear not knowing that that was special as
soon as she walked away I wouldn't play
anybody else's music I'd only played my
stuff not realizing that that's called
songwriter he took those writing skills
to college and joined a band this was a
college band how can we meet all the
girls in the Dhamma tour band you know I
was not supposed to be the career that
[Music]
band would become the Commodores did you
ever doubt that you could achieve
success when you're 19 to 25 everything
is possible
we're the black Beatles we are the
Commodores and we're going to take over
the world
did you believe you were the black we
were the black Beatles I believed it I
knew it by the way not one song didn't
have one song but you already were going
to be we were the opening act for the
Jackson 5 and we're on our way
the Commodores ruled the charts in the
1970s but the attention Ricci was
getting as a songwriter convinced him it
was time to go solo 14 years of amazing
times I always tell people ever dude
thank God for the Commodores because
without them I never would have
discovered Lionel Richie and the world
discovered a superstar
[Music]
well you tell me the story how it you
first got the idea for hello it was a
joke
my producer James Anthony Carmichael he
was coming by the house and he walked
around the corner I said hello is it me
you're looking for and I'm falling out
laughing he turned to miss a finish that
I finished the song and we lunched it up
with strings for ever and for it with
just nothing but just strings and heavy
action
see
but one of Ritchie's most crowning
achievements was anything but a solo
project
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
teaming up with Michael Jackson in 1985
the pair wrote we are the world and
recorded it with more than 40 singers
including the biggest stars of the day
the single raised more than 60 million
dollars for African famine relief every
time I hear the song it's even larger
than I could ever imagine
[Music]
at the end that night we finally played
it back at 7:30 8 o'clock in the morning
it was another planet
it was another planet
[Applause]
did you ever imagine back in Alabama
that you'd end up in this life it's not
where you start it's where you end up
but when I want to go get grounded I go
back to Tuskegee Alabama I still have
that home I was born and raised by the
Tuskegee Airmen I am standing on the
shoulders of those people when a kid
sees me pick up this Kennedy Center
Honor I want him to understand that this
is possible it's not where you started
it's what he end up my PhD
[Music]
music out of control we've been singing
we let our child miss our childhood yeah
say you say me though from White Nights
I mean it like it's just my Russian
background that that song just impacted
my entire family hello I remember
Michael hush Shan Shan Doyle at the time
ballerina girl he go on dance on the
ceiling even today I like how he said
that when you're young anything is
possible and it's so true
you can hear Alex Wagner's entire
interview with Lionel Richie on our CBS
this morning podcast find it on iTunes
and Apple's podcast app